let's talk about San Diego Comic-Con and
the possibility that Stargate might not
be announced after all welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel on holiday in North Wales look
at that beautiful
[Music]
so nothing has really changed on the
plan for San Diego Comic-Con for Amazon
and MGM the only thing that's really
changed is that it's now only two weeks
away
and where do we currently stand well I'm
still being told there is a plan in
place for MGM that holds several stalls
and a couple of conference rooms at San
Diego Comic-Con to announce star game
but that those plans have not been
finalized they've not been finalized
basically because of the writers strike
shockingly
the idea has always been that they would
love to announce this another Comic Con
along with Robocop and a couple of other
projects
but there's been a disagreement within
Amazon and MGM about whether it's the
right thing to do
is it you know gonna make them look like
evil uncaring business people rather
than you know an up-and-coming studio if
they just ignore what's going on with
the writers and and now it's a major
project
now other companies including Amazon and
MGM to be fair have announced other
smaller projects over the last few weeks
and you know certain deals and things
are still going on there are certain
beliefs and certain quarters that
actually negotiations can't be going on
at the moment because the rotor strike
and that's not true because the
executives Executives the people
actually make these decisions they're
not on strike so of course there are
lots and lots of conversations within
the big Executives attitude Joe's going
on at the moment
problem comes in it's all about
perception and how they're then
perceived how the business is perceived
and that is a concern for Amazon
particularly because their perception is
not very good so they're very very aware
that they don't want to tarnish MGM with
the same brush so
they may if the writer strike is still
going on decide not to announce at San
Diego Comic-Con there's also been
another discussion actually in that what
are they even going to be announcing
because they can't start writing they
can't start really any serious
development because of the writer's
strike so really they would just be
announcing the intention
now that could still happen
but an intention to do something can be
done very easily just with a press
announcement it doesn't need quite a big
expensive presentation at San Diego
Comic-Con with actors Etc present
now we believe they're doing a movie and
we believe they're actually quite far
down the road of development we think
there might even be a script already in
place we think several of the actors
like Amanda Tapping Michael Shanks Etc
are going to be involved in this now
if that is the case
then actually doing a big presentation
it's only what Comic-Con could be quite
exciting because we can have the actors
on the stage we can have RDA there etc
etc
but
if it isn't as far as we think
then they can't
while actors potentially and writers are
on strike now I actually think is the
actors potentially going to Strikers the
biggest problem now about three weeks
ago
because I've got sources that work over
at places like
um quite a big talent agency I know that
there was a belief
um that actually this was going to get
resolved quite quickly that there had
been a big breakthrough with the writers
now that was true
um one of the big breakthroughs was
actually did agree to do something in
line with what the directors agreed with
with AI that basically AI cannot be
hired as a human being on a film set now
that sounds obvious
but it's actually quite an important
technicality in that a writer cannot be
replaced by AI producing a script so an
evil executive over at Disney with a big
mustache gone all the time cannot
program an AI
to produce a script and then use that
script and to produce a movie it's not
allowed to do it under this new
agreement with the contract with the wga
so
AI can only be used as a tool by a
writer so an AI could be used to
generate something that a writer would
then polish up Etc
um but it can not only be used as a tool
rather than an actual person
now there are still arguments
unfortunately going on about money it's
the residuals there's really the major
sticking point
now it felt like again as I say two
weeks ago that those issues had been
resolved but unfortunately they're still
dragging on
the actor's guild agreed to extend their
deadline until the 12th of July which is
only in a few days
the biggest problem I've always said
this
Amazon will not announce this
if the writers are on strike probably
they will definitely not announce us if
the actors have gone strike as well
because then they've got a much bigger
problem they've got to deal with
so until we know what's going on with
the actors basically this week they're
not going to finalize any agreement or
any plan to enact Stargate
and we might independent to wait just a
little bit longer
like we haven't waited long enough
at least the question of whether whether
they will or they won't develop a new
star get has been answered we know they
will
it's just when
guys get to the comments tell me what
you think does this make sense is it
logical or is it just one more
irritation and you know do you actually
get to a point where you don't care now
just a note has been developed and we'll
go from there that's where I'm at
get into the comments tell me exactly
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification do all those buttons
and hopefully I'll see you next time
foreign